hello everyone and welcome to a game
that can only be described as a highly
enjoyable it's a game from round four of
the 2018 isle of man chess tournament
and displayed between Gawain Jones and
Luke HD now going Jones I believe needs
no introduction you may remember last
year from 2017 Isle of Man chess
tournament where he played against
Magnus Carlsen across and blundered the
piece but then he was able to beat the
Gawain Jones nevertheless after
blundering the piece and after that
onigiri said in an interview that Magnus
Carlsen is a piece stronger than
everyone else pretty sure I covered that
game on my channel if if I have I will
include a link to it in the description
below if not then you know could forget
I said anything
but he faces a 12 year old international
master from India [ __ ] HD that's a very
exotic name as I've never seen a name
with only a letter as as you have here
Booker T but I did check it out and it
seems to be this does seem to be his
name I will also include a very nice
article and a very nice YouTube video we
buy in the chess base India in the
description below so feel free to check
that out as well
where you can learn a lot more about
this young gentleman here so without
further ado going Jones has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have d5
c4 c6 and here in the Slav defense Jones
decides to play see captors on d5 the
exchange variation see chapters on d5
and now Bishop to g5 not certainly not
an everyday move especially to be played
in classical time format as it
immediately you can see that it violates
basic chess principles you know tine
it's often said that you should
definitely bring your Knights into the
game before developing your bishops and
you have immediately exchanged a pair of
pawns in the center so probably he
decided to go for this variation to get
his young opponent out of the book very
early in the game and okay we have h6
questioning the whereabouts the future
whereabouts of this bishop we have
Russia back to h4 and now well you can
concern ormally can just start
developing pieces Knight to c6 for
example Bishop to a5 and so on and so on
black decides if my stronger grandmaster
alone and decided to violate chess
principles from the start I'm gonna do
do that as well Queen to b6 bringing out
your queen too early can sometimes be a
bit of a nuisance and okay this does
come with a tempo the b2 point is under
attack but Jones invites him to capture
we have Knight to c3 inviting Queen
captures and b2 and again black can just
ignore this okay you do have a queen
into the game a bit early but still this
dark square Bishop is all the way on h4
there's no way to question the
whereabouts of the Queen just yet I am
black and just ignore it with east six
as simply defending the d5 pawn or or
even by e5 if he wants to complicate
things a lot but he accepts the
challenge young Mukesh plays Queen
captures on b2 and now it becomes a very
very interesting game Knight captures on
d5 already Jones is threatening Knights
to c7 check winning the rook and okay
Lucas plays east six a very nice
defensive maneuver now nice to see seven
would actually lose you the game because
after King 37 the knight is attacked and
you're gonna lose this Knight if you
play something like Knight captures here
then Bishop to b4 check loses the game
you have to block wink after somebody -
this will be checkmate
so after this east six move rook to b1 a
very nice move by Jones Queen k3 and now
comes Queen to c2 a very nice piece
sacrifice because now if pawn captures
Queen captures unsee it will be
checkmate as the bishop is slicing all
the way through the dark squares and the
King has nowhere to go so after Queen to
c2 we have nice - a6 covering the c7
square but also now the rook is guarding
the bishop on c8 we have E for opening
up this path for this light square
Bishop so he can jump all the way to b5
so now he captures and if I would be
again a losing move because of as we
already mentioned Bishop to b5 check
Bishop to d7 commercial captures you do
have to capture
the king has nowhere to go King captures
in town rook captures on b7 and now you
can either go closer into the center
with your king and you will get get to
checkmate it there or if you go back to
simply Queen to c6 and again it will be
checkmate
so a very very difficult position to
play for black Bishop to d6 by young
Gugu kesh Bishop to b5 check nonetheless
King to f8 and Dena clumps and Knights
the c3 the so the knife comes back and
what do we have here well a black did
grab opponent B - but why - grabbed the
pawn back so black is not a pawn up
anymore and still his King is on f8 but
White's King is still in the center of
the board so it's still a very very
complicated game nice to be for
attacking a Jones Queen uncie - we have
Queen today - and now comes a six
attacking the bishop but should be back
to e2 and of now even g5 attacking the
other Bishop forcing him to come to g3
to exchange a parry Bishop Bishop to g3
we have Bishop captures H captures and
not nice back to c6 so it seems a Mukesh
was able to fend off the attack and now
if he can I get his pieces out perhaps
he can still continue playing this game
but there's simply not all that much
time nice to have three by Jones and
here we have Queen back to d6 bringing
the Queen back into the defense but now
okay it's true you there's really no
point in playing Knight captors and g5
even though you cannot capture here as
you would lose a book but I can just
ignore this Queen captures on d4 that's
kind of the point of Queen d6 and I've
between characters Knight captures you
would also grab a pawn and this Knight
really isn't doing all that much on g5
you just have to bring it back and then
more exchanges would come and so on and
so on so after Queen 36 Jones finds a
different approach how to continue this
attack he plays d5 and okay we have ECAP
force on d5 Knight chapter son b5 and
now comes Knight to G to e7 allowing
this Knight capture son g5 move but
there's really not all that much for
example King to g7 that this does defend
the rook here but then Queen the c3
check is very day
Knight to f6 blocking and the now comes
rook to d1 with the threat of Knight v6
a discovered attack to the Queen and
also threatening the rook if you defend
this rook to b8 then you get Knight to
f4 and this will be deadly
your queen is under attack and you do
have to play something if you play Queen
two before you offer a trade of Queens
but now this nice to h5 move comes with
check the night is still pinned and
after we move the King if you you don't
want to move the King away from the
defense of the night so after King to g6
you're gonna get Queen captures on
before night capture Sun before and now
the deadly 95 chick pink has to move
away from the knife finally Knight
captures on f6 black loses a piece and
the game it will be an easy victory for
white so a very difficult position
so Knight G to e7 instead and only now
Knight captures on g5 we have Queen to
g6 and now comes Knight to b6 attacking
this rook a very nice maneuvering the
move would the night and that comes with
an attack on the rook and if you don't
have a move that crushes your opponent
instantly you can you know threaten to
win to win a rope here rook to b8 you do
have to react to this and now comes Luke
to h4 preparing group to f4 and the
Black has a lot on his mind now ideas
like a Knight captures on f7 followed by
Bishop to h5 are definitely here so
Queen to g7 first making room for the
night and was like f6 if you want to get
rid of the knight will be easily met
with Knight to h3 and after something
like h5 as you don't want all our Bishop
to h5 and then simply nice captures rook
captures and after rook captures on b7
black is completely busted and that
white will have an easy game here so
after rook to h4 we have Queen to g7 and
now comes knife captures on f7 Jones
goes in for the kill
King captures on f7 and now rook to f4
with check now we have King to e8 and
now Bishop to h5 again with check nice
to g6 blocking as you don't really have
any other moves the Queen is completely
controlling the d-file the rope is
controlling the F file so you can either
block with the Queen there's not much
point in doing that so nice to g6
we have we
2d6 a very nice way to continue the
attack now this comes with a double
attack against this night you do have to
defend against this rock the g8 and now
you can win this in in a lot of
different ways you can go Knight d5 rook
to d1 but Jones does it in the most
simplest of ways
he simply plays Bishop captures and g6
this comes with check the King has
nowhere to go
Queen captures and now of course you can
all see the move without even pausing
opposing the video here it is of course
rook to f8 check black still has nowhere
to go he has to capture the rook and it
was it was in this position that young
Gugu coach D decided to resign the game
as now rook captures I would lose you to
Queen Queen after Sun g6 and you would
you would not have enough material to
continue the game because for example if
roadblocks then comes Knight captures
rook captures and Queen to g8 check Rock
f8 Queen e6 check and now after Knight
blocks
rook captures on b7 and to defend
against checkmate you don't really have
a lot of options you have to play a rope
to f7 but then simply rope capture Sonny
7 you removed the defender of the rock
and c8 wrote capture screen captures you
have a queen against the night it's an
easy game and no point in continuing
this young international master Lucas D
sees this and after rope to f8 he
decided to resign the game so like I
said I hope I do hope you enjoyed it it
was a very enjoyable game from round 4
of 2018 iron chest festival I would like
to thank even Daniel savoring and Alex
pearl for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
like I said feel free to check out the
interview and the article with the about
end with young you could be in the
description below there's really a lot
to learn about him as he's one of the
newest stars in India so I do hope you
enjoyed that as well and I will cover
perhaps even more games from round 5 so
we're gonna talk about the standings a
bit there as it is now the half of the
tournament and I will continue the Bobby
Fischer series no worries about that so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for
and I'll see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content thank you
all and I'll see you soon